what are you actually gonna do this is
the rule because of what you actually
were you actually gonna do this for 35
weeks 35 [ __ ] sick of it but [ __ ]
sick of it I love it
same old same old guys follow us once we
are follow us on instagram sign up to
our patreon by just going on your
[ __ ] what's it called your App Store
download patreon search ships and gigs
subscribe to us on YouTube shit's and
gigs podcast yeah mum we're all over the
globe on Facebook as well merch is
active oh that reminds me when you
mention about patreon so I'll give them
another shout-out anyway cuz it's just a
big dick move my life Sebastian big dick
energy Sebastian so when we said a few
episodes back we had a patron subscribe
call Sebastian and we shot with him out
I let him know they subscribe but we Lam
no Abby Abby Abby Abby happy hour out
Trump now you're Gabby now Abby Abby a
year so Abby was paying more than him my
message back up sees donations and was
like bruh after that little thing I had
to up my contributions I was like that's
a big dick that's real [ __ ] [ __ ] as
real [ __ ] I say what you think what
you [ __ ] afford ten out Sebastian hey
hold that ten up hold us oh man won't
miss that told that spots if you're
broke when I read that message I was
like this guy this guy swinging dick
[ __ ] he gift for Sebastian Moss
kapositas [ __ ] [ __ ] he guessed her
name rikes slang in dick big cats
ticket
yeah senior father you gotta talk to me
man will you go for me
thank you wrong um over go for you guys
today
no sequins Shh oh my god
do you remember life before mobile
phones mm-hmm do you remember the times
where you had to call someone and
actually know their number big man
yes I do for one and I remember having
to cool I remember because I've told you
before I hated doing phone calls that's
a kid I [ __ ] yeah hated here and I
remember having to ring my boy asking if
I could have a sleepover his house and I
had to ring the landline yeah and I knew
his mom obviously his mom's gonna pick
up yeah
and bro I was so terrified anytime I
wanted to speak to Donny and they're not
ringing in his mom would our session
hello hi hi I think her name was mrs.
yeah
his name was Lewis Lewis Collins and
then after her hi mrs. Collins James
Lewis his friend James Lewis they're his
new so to speak please I just so
embarrassing front so embarrassing I
remember my dad watching me do it just
like some [ __ ] from Hyde yeah life was
all mobile friends was long
do you remember life when mobile phones
were new when you first had your first
phone yeah I remember when I first got
my first one stolen oh Jesus I had a
Nokia 80 I think it's got an 82 10 it
was a red-and-black quite a small one
gave the spider yeah I was in yes 7 I
was in year 7 I had finished I was I had
a fit I had I had have finished PE or
either finished like a rugby practice
but all I know is that I had to go to
change me to change it must be rugby
practice I think it was after school and
then I looked to my luck I was getting
on my [ __ ] and I was like [ __ ] where's
my phone back then I lived in Crystal
Palace I went all the way back home and
was that mama
someone's stolen my phone
so obviously I was petrified like that's
my first phone my parents boy for me
like obviously back then you went
getting your own phone yeah in your rags
don't [ __ ] lose this phone how else
am I going to contact you can so I wish
I was [ __ ] petrified and then I
explained the situation I think they
beat me our Cartman box I probably did
[ __ ] pricks personally then I've got
am I think about 3210 after that I think
yeah nokia was running ting right now
but yeah fam life before mobile phones
was was crazy I don't know how my
parents did it because my parents moved
here my person is at UK in 1990 so just
the year before I was born
hmm I'm mobile phones went around then
obviously to my knowledge anyway unless
you were like this bridge yes you had
that big antenna yeah you had a big day
no one's rocking up and back them in
like just like normal class cities and
not rocking them since it's only if
you're rich or rocking it yeah yeah yeah
I remember my mum had an address book
like a full-blown Oh address book I
remember and I think in these
Millennials have no idea how easy
they've got like babies of nowadays
would only ever know a mobile phone 100%
they won't know what a landline it don't
know what a landline is but they'll
never know who has a landline true I
don't have a landline I don't have
another line all right was the last time
I use my landline phone my kids aren't
gonna know we're landline phone is
they're not gonna know that's crazy bro
I don't remember the last time I picked
up what I might ever that's crazy
yes nuts but that's crazy I think the
only ever time I used a landline was
back when I had run out of credit back
before they were contracts yeah remember
um on t-mobile back in not not even
t-mobile what was before what was before
team over one to one
that was before team about one yeah and
you had the no 1 2 ones before team of
Bubba on team over I had the 5 day pass
thing ok remember you remember the 5 day
pass no I wasn't on that [ __ ] oh so on
t-mobile you had like you paid 5 pounds
and then every other t-mobile user the
messages will be free Oh
user unlimitedly for the month but it's
only 2 t-mobile users oh you top up
tempers and use only 5 pounds of that
for
to one thing or for the fire part among
thick you can message or team about
people for free but you'd have fire
powers of F so up C because it used to
take data every time you text and your
cool back then and I remember used to do
that and that's how we used to like
speak to girls and stuff for everyone
because obviously doesn't know what's up
then I just like time has [ __ ]
changed bro
I remember when it was a straight SMS
ting mmm and I'm chatting to gal but I
need to squeeze everything I want to say
into the first thing yeah because if
you've carried over if it's it's a thing
if the full stock goes over the line
yeah I can't afford that it was I think
was like wasn't like Bros stressful ah
every time I accidentally did it and I
didn't realize because it wouldn't tell
you you're going into yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so you'll just it would just send it
without sending one or two and I'm like
bastard prick you [ __ ] prick I
remember I rinsed money on girls back in
like yeah you're like 11 year 12 I think
I spent a whole ten pound on text when
our steaks are they go ah yeah yeah been
there you do you paint to receive as
well no you just pay to send you just
paid to send I was rinsing money on goes
to text saying rinsing I say believe it
couldn't believe it same bro and when I
hadn't no credit
my phone's just blowing up that's when
people want to chat to me I've got no
credit I'm skint xt @ xt x XA I can try
to no one and there's no there's nothing
like Wi-Fi is not gonna help
I don't think there was Wi-Fi but you
can yeah it was no apps they were no
apps apps bro it was text and that's it
effects text contact
snake snake everyone had snake lit so
lit sex contact snake and settings and
that's probably it alarm handle on there
and saying that's it I don't think as
much else and the phone book obviously
that was it yeah [ __ ] man we have time
to be alive well then yeah I was amazing
baby that's all you knew
you're nothing but [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
remember when I got the first iPhone
when yn3 wasn't no before that I got the
iPhone 2g
2g when we yeah we present you guys had
blackberries oh yeah and I was livid you
know what it was because I was I refuse
to have no love of libraries
yeah but bbm was the tape no you're not
[ __ ] anyone and they don't know bbm
yeah if you don't know baby have you're
not having sex and that's the end of the
text phone and I'm like I've got an
iPhone family like no one could touch me
rock up to uni massive our iPhone no one
gives off no one gave a [ __ ] no one gave
a single [ __ ] if you didn't have the
ping-ping-ping no one's fool bro and I'm
just like anyone want to download ping
anyone wanna chat to me on paper nah
what's that I don't think I ever saw one
person on pink bbm was a lick if you
didn't a baby him you had nothing what's
your PIN bro there are times in my house
someone come on
bbm know so then I had to get your old
phone you get a new blackberry and I was
I broke give me daddy
give me death I remember just chatting
two bad things on bbm hug there what a
horrible times of your life horrible
disgusting barbaric time to be alive and
now phones are so expensive now I know
but it's far more expensive god knows
what no I know
so don't think it's crazy that what was
it that broke blackberry I think it must
have an Instagram I think Instagram must
have destroyed blackberry because it
wasn't on and what's up yeah yeah cuz it
wasn't you hadn't [ __ ] all on blackberry
yeah well we had all we had going for us
was pin yeah yes the pin yeah yeah
that's it bbm there wasn't anything else
going for us but when Instagram drops I
got straight back on the iPhone I was
like what this brother got the iPhone
you asked for Instagram there was things
on their craft yeah things I've ever
used to front of the pages when is there
frustration for like baddies are awesome
[ __ ] pork nation
he was just bitching nation but this is
before they were white girls this was
before there was even really Instagram
famous girls
it was just accounts yeah it was just
that would just post deployment team
yeah no one really had fame from it boy
those were the good old over the good
old days
Oh amazing [ __ ] amazing
that was funny that was actually very
funny I loved those times when I my
first time I think the first time I had
an iPhone was in year or my second I
want to say my second year of uni I
think was it my second year it really
was a college no I was definitely Rock
even blackberry for time and then after
blackberry I got upgrade I got another
blackberry and then I've got a thank you
so much
I've got Motorola RAZR I was cold I had
a Motorola RAZR thank you oh yes I'm a
Motorola RAZR
back in I had a razor I had a razor I
had knock years I'm lucky as for ty I
knock his forever and then my first non
Nokia was that amazing I had a
blackberry black had two blackberries
and then I moved on to an iPhone I've
had I phones for years now I've had
iPhones I've had I had the iPhone 2g the
iPhone three the iPhone 4 the iPhone 5
then went from iPhone 5 to iPhone 7 then
went from seven to did I go seven to ten
oh and seven to ten seventy so because
they didn't bring a nine out that did
they there wasn't a nine is there we
went straight from a seven there's seven
c7s there isn't a a plus and then yeah
they did the eight and then our free
shoulder eight with the first eight plus
kind of days yeah and then they did the
tenth and yeah so I've yeah I've had
obviously skipped a couple in the middle
for these two-year contracts but boy
yeah I'm about I'm again another fine oh
no I don't see much
of getting anything by up although it is
now G and then when they took the
airports they solidified it episode
apples are amazingly there remain no one
that doesn't have airports you need to
get because they're [ __ ] good I
needed this so bad you need every day
better thank you so much this is my head
was pounding
that's nectar but yeah man there was
something stupid I'm gonna ask you what
the [ __ ] are gonna say you ever have
an argument of yourself no I'm not
arguing with yourself
but you have a play out an argument you
actually speak the words from both
anchor in the shower water so I do in
the car that's the only face imagine you
in the car it might be I was very funny
I can imagine you doing that
that's so funny in a car on the way to
well [ __ ] sake bro this is what
happens if I'm in the car on the way to
work I'll play out the entire if I'm
running late so let's say I'm running
late and then driving in a lot [ __ ] I'm
gonna be late and then I know what my
managers gonna say when I get in and
then I'm if I'm pissed off I will have
the entire back and forth conversation
for like 10 minutes and the whole thing
yeah and then I'll win I'll make sure I
win hundred percent and then I'm not
bang I know I'm gonna say no I know I'm
gonna say no perfect all the time I do
it in a shower I don't know what cuz I
think when I'm in a shower that's
probably my only time I can think
because I'm just to myself am I thought
not when I'm in a room or when I'm with
here watch the TV or whatever obviously
never at work I forgot when I'm in my
shower
that's my only that's my me time yeah
yeah and when I've got stuff on my mind
that involves it's another party I argue
myself yeah I argue myself if I don't
why I do it bro it's funny I've done my
entire life I used to do it on road that
guy if I was walking before I had like a
car or anything like that
if I was a teenage and I'll just walking
in the street I don't them right yeah
and I've actually hear myself speaking
and someone would walk past me 100% 100%
and
as I said the thing is well um when I
sexually the other day and when I said
if do you have you ever walked past I
would like sometimes as I'm getting
older I might became crazy I'm saying
things with my mouth that I thought I
said in my head you are getting crazy
exactly so do you might actually ever
downs like how'd you ever walk past I
think I should say tits out because
obviously this is obviously me if you
had walk in we've been we've done it our
whole lives this is the day we ever met
in your walk in every guy does it [ __ ]
it if you're walking I'm gonna kill
flesh over and then if you're walking
down the road whatever walking through
town and you see a spice and like if at
its finest your sense it's a fat yeah
we'll be walking together yeah and just
it's like well boy you're both see at
exact same time tits yeah and that's
just how it is
more body fat wherever or we'll make a
facial expression mmm we'll make a
facial expression so we've done that for
so many years so many times that now
when I am walking by myself yeah I'll
look up and be like tits and I would
actually say it I will actually say it
and I've been in situations where the
girl is close enough to hear me say oh
wow it's only happen once or twice Baban
like I'll be like walking on my phone to
do dinner would look up tits she's there
that's one has two takes you at the
other day I'm going nuts lose my [ __ ]
don't think I've ever said out loud when
I bought myself Bob obviously always
thought it was something I mean groups
are with you or whoever I verbalize it
and he sort out make faces and stuff
because it needs to be acknowledged I
feel like it's it's a gift to us so you
know it's a gift to us a gift to us you
guys I think NASA famous oh yeah you
know that's hilarious
speaking of that reminds me what would
you said a minute ago speaking of it's
like in some models and you know when we
spoke about the other day like only fans
yeah and we're talking about
how obvious ly ad I've never I would
never do in only fans mm-hmm
like I would never pay yeah I'd never
host or yeah so it never paid I would
never pay for one yeah but more time do
you ever look at do you ever you know
how to explain it what am I trying to
say so let's take Kylie Jenner for
example yeah you see her yeah basically
every day yeah so your see Peters of a
basically every day I'm a provocative
and obviously she's disgustingly buff
mm-hmm so do you ever viously after it's
been going on for years now so this has
been going on for years and you've done
it every day and you've seen her every
day yeah
do you ever not have the thought in your
head like are we gonna [ __ ] or not
do you ever obviously you know you're
not yeah but it's such an integral part
of your day now yeah seem provocative
pictures of this one chair do you ever
think like big man oh we like what do
you ever get angry at Kylie like what
you do into man not necessarily
Kylie probably with other people like
other like models and stuff I wouldn't
necessarily say with Kylie purely
because obviously it's fact it's
fictional it's never gonna happen
yeah well I think I do with some people
where it's not necessarily a
plausibility but it's more likely than
kylie jenner you know I mean anything is
more I only think it's more likely the
kylie jenner is never gonna happen
is this Oh imagine imagine if she
actually just slid in
all right scenario here we go let me get
comfortable it's [ __ ] wire I'm away
right big man scenario is yeah for me so
thank you so you're chilling one day
we're just chilling we've just wrapped
up recording cameras off audios off
microwave or just chain
just uploaded a brand-new video and
views are ticking in whatever comments
are dripping in Laie
and then you're just scrolling through
scrolling through and you just see one
mm-hmm that says something like saw you
guys on tick-tock yeah
massive fan yeah and it says it just
says Kylie on it doesn't it nothing else
just says Kylie on it and the thumbnails
so small you see lips yeah you know you
still at this point you don't you don't
think it's you don't think it's anything
you just say oh snap click on it yeah
and you're like rah mmm that's that
looks like Kylie Jenner I can't be sure
yeah obviously it's YouTube can't see
anything right yeah yeah so yeah yeah
all right that's weird that was like I
dunno but she's probably using a picture
whatever mmm
then you go on to our tick-tock mm-hmm
you know she sounds from tick-tock
whoever scrolling up and it says Kylie
Jenner like this video kylie jenner like
this video Kylie Jenner like this video
cuz you know about this video and you're
like hang on yes you click you see a fat
blue tick on a profile you're like rah
that's her that's her you go to mrs. so
let's say I'm not even here now yeah so
you you go to message me yeah on
Instagram or something hmm
and then as you as you open up your
inbox to open up our last chat on
Instagram yeah you see a request there
this is on your private you see a
request there you click it another big
blue tick uh Kylie Jenner ah and she's
like hi if you had aa to our watch a few
of the
I was a few others I've got a few other
episodes now yeah you may not doing the
thing I don't know if you're ever in
Calabasas but if you are shout me shout
me Oh what are you okay
what are you actually gonna do this is
the rule because of what you act what
are you actually gonna do so let's say
this happens tomorrow yeah for example
okay no no not tomorrow hmm no
quarantine nothing no quarantine no
quarantine now you can fly if you want
to Kylie Jenner yeah but she hasn't said
meet me here now oh yeah you just said
if you're ever in the area slide in and
well so far now but she hasn't said come
meet me I'm free this time she doesn't
even say when she's definitely gonna be
in an agency traveling schedule and even
but she has categorically said to you if
you had if you were ever about money in
around in Calabasas shout shout me slide
in and we'll walk up grab a coffee as
I'm I'd love to like I'd love to grab a
coffee
she didn't message me this she just
messaged you and she said food had she
didn't say energy age and I say hi guys
she said message your gram I said is you
what you actually gonna do are you gonna
stay here in Manchester and just show
everyone this message that you got I
never act on it or you physically
actually gonna go to LA well first of
all I'm I'm showing everyone that's the
first thing I'm doing I'm showing
everyone because this doesn't happen
this just it just doesn't happen
I'm screenshot now sending to you send
it to the boys in its group chart and
I'm just like man dem we have to go to
California we have to go to we have to
go to LA whether or not I potentially
see her or a link up it's like whatever
I'm like obviously we wanted to go what
was it two years ago four years ago
wanted to go who said hmm
and when Jay was that so I'm like we
have to go whatever you guys need to do
to go this summer we're going this
summer all right and then we're going
I'm gonna message her before that oh I'm
actually
it's come I would never tell her I was
thinking of coming up I'm say uh you
know what coincidentally I was actually
paint gonna come in let's see yeah yeah
I'm funny you should say that I'm gonna
be there in June when I'm about like the
week before I get there whatever the
paper I get that I'll shout you just so
we're like we're honest we cross parts
or blow all right I don't
we'll play from there so once we booked
yeah so that's to say that she's up
sounds great she just hits you up on her
on a basic quiet laisse sounds good
or sounds great whatever so June rolls
around actually booked it so everyone's
actually pulled their money together and
we've booked the thing and we're like
cool LA sounds good like can't wait you
message her you message her one more on
our way to the airport
mm and like oh just give me a shout
actually no no no do you okay so at this
point we've got the whole thing are you
gonna message her before we fly over
there or you gonna message up when we're
there I will let her know obviously I
would have message a prior and said that
coincidentally we're going to be there
in June 11 yeah and then I'll message
her probably a few days before we fly
and be like just just a rekindle kind of
thing I'm actually gonna be out in LA in
the next couple of days because I don't
think we would speak in between that
point we would first smoke and when I'm
actually flying reason to yeah so I'll
just remind a lot
I'm flying there in a few days just to
let you know bro bro if you want us to
link up we can link up see this is why I
gave my own this is when I get my head
on yeah and I'll be I'll tight that
whole message exactly we said when we're
still in England I would attack the
whole message and I wouldn't thinking
[ __ ] she's gonna think I'm thirsty boy
because I'm I'm letting her before I've
even got on the flight yeah yeah that's
the message again when I get there oh
and whenever when i hook this thing up
yeah I would you want to play it blase
I wanna play oh yeah I wanna play
crystal cool wow I can't [ __ ] this side
it's Kylie Jenner i--'cause [ __ ] it up
alright cool so you've messaged uh yeah
and you've messaged her now said oh
we're gonna be flying out in a couple
days etc cetera cetera
she reads it don't reply mm-hmm well
gone when we were actually in LA now so
we're in LA we've sailed him we've been
there for two days she's followed me
correct she's followed Jesus follow me
so as soon as we land yeah I'm
instagramming that were about and if
she's seen it okay I'm not responded or
said anything then I won't beg it yeah
that's a lie I would still probably beg
every I still probably message her after
I've mostly seen it be like oh just to
let you know I'm here so when I'm here
for like a week for example if you have
one of me laughing off of it if you want
to meet up still let me know blah blah
and if we go from that but as long as I
know she's seen the video on Instagram
stories and the story then I would know
she's active she responds she responds
if she doesn't then I guess we're just
in LA it's not a bad thing obviously I
want to go to LA regardless so but it's
heavy boy that's that's how I play I
play tactically mmm if she's follow me
that she's gonna ream us watch you're
not gonna see my server but if she sees
the story then
alright cool sorry they say she hasn't
seen the story mm-hmm hasn't seen any
other stories the whole week
she read she read that message when you
sending it didn't reply we've been in a
for a week she hasn't seen a single
story that you've posted you're like
you're just assume she's not even about
then she messages on the day that we're
leaving we're on our way to the airport
she messages and just says I'll sorry
just got just got back to LA from
[ __ ] wherever
Texas wherever if you're still about
shout me lay off and we're on our way to
the airport home what are you doing
you've got no money you've got no money
left so you've got like that's it you've
got 200 quid in your account
someone said someone office say let's
just say we all come to get more without
cool if you need to stay yeah here's
enough money look we can we can get you
a flight home yeah but you're gonna stay
here myself you can't will change our
flies you're gonna stay away so you're
gonna sort your own accommodation and
you know food and stuff um yeah you guys
are gonna have to figure out what kind
of category says she's free tonight
oh I'm doing it I'm doing it for the
story weather why [ __ ] or not it's
gotta be one of the great stories ever
talk family I feel like if I do it will
be ganked mm that'll be a dope story but
if I stay and I don't [ __ ] up it'll be
the best story ever Dre I mean because
it'll be so funny uh how [ __ ] up my
life is that I would I would [ __ ]
stay and without all you man to
potentially [ __ ] Kylie Jenner and the
trifon must go through you sleeping on
the streets big man I've got nowhere to
you guys have given me your last P to
just change my flight come I don't know
what you're doing that's that's the
God's honest truth
that's that's what I'm saying be the
best story if it doesn't happen you'll
be a great story if it does happen a
[ __ ] great story and maybe a story
Bobby funny if it didn't happen and
that's the reason why I'll do it because
I'll be able to tell it on here again
true that's the reason why I do it I'll
be amazing funny if it happened I
wouldn't say it if it didn't happen I'd
say it facts ah because nowadays you
have to do stuff for this laughs I would
be sweating from sweating I'll be so
intimidate and the thing this is
warehouse imagine how scared you'd be
very much she hasn't given you her
number or anything our only form of
contact you've got it's Instagram yeah
yeah yeah and she said I'm about tonight
she hasn't given you a time anything
your boys have just got on the plane
they're gone yeah we're gone ma'am
you're in Los Angeles alone with 200
dollars in your account with a hope and
a dream with a hope that she's actually
about tonight you haven't made any
concrete past she's so frustratingly
blase about this whole thing she don't
give a [ __ ] as soon as you mana got on
the plane I'm stressed yeah stress
because I think what the [ __ ] am i doing
yeah what the [ __ ] am I actually do it
yeah yeah I'll be stressed by I don't
know
and then thinking I still have to pay
cool I have to still pay a have to pay
polar bear cool yeah
polar bear cool bro
I can't miss adjust six times okay cool
so what's the plan
I can't let know that all my boys have
left me I can't let no I've got no money
like the end this hostel and this has to
land like the [ __ ] or no [ __ ] the
link-up has to lie yeah we have to link
I don't know how he's gonna happen we
have to link ah stressful stressful time
I would definitely do I would do it for
the story I'd have to pay for the story
because I see like I said it'll be so
much funny if I did it even link Oh or
didn't want it that would be the
greatest story it would the greatest
story it would because I'd have the
evidence to back it mmm
whereas if we actually did link it'll be
an amazing story now told you man mmm
but you have to keep that looking out
that would be a key that would be it
would never be a 16 gigs experience yeah
you have to keep that low-key [ __ ] one
night with Kylie
Oh a show from the farm one night with
Kylie oh I've been evening that'll be a
luscious if I wouldn't want it to end I
think no words that would be the night I
go rounds I have to go out do you know I
mean I'm popping viagra oh I'm pop in
every cialis I'm taking it I'm taking
two it ranks my heart will have to take
the strain
oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] oh what an amazing
particular Jesus the fear of up I'll be
so [ __ ] if you guys be like yeah you
guys [ __ ] stay stay stay
no you guys tell me to stay and I'm like
okay cool cool cool cool we get old gas
we go I guess you give me all the money
that I need to stay and then I see you
guys go I'm petrified
Oh hundred what have I done yeah hundred
what I've I just Harper to 500 but
you're fine I'm in Los Angeles by myself
granted that doesn't sound that bad but
no money no money no concrete plans just
your suitcase in your hand what if I die
oh my god what you're Harvey across the
[ __ ] world fam we know
we're long gone I'm on the plane snoozy
he'll be petrified I'm looking like I
would be [ __ ] terrified for a
potential date that may or may not
happen no bro
I would like said I'll still do it but
right it could just be coffee it could
imagine if you go for the whole thing
you stay everything she links you she's
like our cool whereabouts are you now
and you're just like some like in it
Queensbridge Boulevard and she's like
and she's an uncle there's actually a
Starbucks there I'll meet you there and
then she meets you at the Starbucks you
guys have a coffee and she's a cool nice
good meeting you
but we should do this again and then she
dips that's a whole thing done and then
you still go away for tomorrow to get
your flight where am i staying exactly
exactly and up there the airport oh
right I have to sleep in the airport
yeah yeah that's good you've had
everything about that I'm doing so angry
angry I'd be so angry
oh that's all that transpired yeah I
Robin nothing transpired the meet up for
coffee really I hate coffee first and
foremost to be fair hey I wouldn't get
I'd get like a mango Frappuccino some
[ __ ] I don't know I hate coffee
but I'll be I would hate that that's all
that transpired I would not be happy
don't get me wrong I'll be gasps but I
would rather nothing happened then meet
up just for coffee all that just for
coffee
cool now now this is when he gets to see
ya now it gets real okay fast forward so
you have your coffee
he's sleeping the airport you go home
you're naked you've made it back yeah
everything's bless you go for like a 10
hours sleep you're [ __ ] shattered
yeah wake up you got a DM from her and
she's our hope you got home safe was
lovely to meet you etcetera etc yeah I
really want to see you again
mm-hmm when can you neck come to LA
what's the deal now now what's the deal
would you mean when next day you coming
her life I know I know I know I'm [ __ ] I
know I'm like 1xe coming to England
babes keys my second and never G she
wouldn't is do you want his post purse
or not the coffee was the was the child
says because he passed the test
you still on thin ice come get this come
like you're just waking your normal job
yeah you can fly to LA if you need to
but this isn't just a thing you can keep
up yeah there's a lifestyle you can
manage I'm gonna be broke bro so do you
tell her yes that you can afford it
this is yeah you can't afford to go back
yeah whenever yeah but are you gonna
leave it three months are you gonna
leave it a month are you gonna be like
[ __ ] I need to go back now but what's
your mindset here what's the game think
I need to go back know that my mindset
straight would be like [ __ ] I need to go
buy new ID not ideally what's the word
I'm looking for
reality wise is not realistically yeah
that's the word realistically it's not
gonna happen I'd want to go back today
as soon as I land on a CD I want to fly
back that same night
yeah realistically it's not gonna happen
I'd probably have to wait months and if
I'd have to tell her that I know
conversation could die off by then I
know the whole thing could die off a
couple of mine I know but she's talking
to man oh I couldn't I'd have to go back
I'd have to go back in a couple weeks I
promise you're TFT ability I couldn't
wear cover Mars I'd have to go back I
wouldn't sleep for the whole two weeks
before I go I'd have to go like it I'll
be stressed from yeah I'll be stressed
and I'll be like right in a rewrite
every DM I sent to her in between there
there has to be perfect yeah every DM
has been perfectly timed
I need to know the whole LA time
different everything I need to hit it
bang bang perfect every time seizure
it'd be the most stressful experience of
my life it'll be the most stressful
[ __ ] experience Bulava I'd hate it I
physically hate it but yeah man that was
interesting for you
am I the [ __ ] go for it
right am I the [ __ ] for not telling
my friend that her crush used to be a
girl right this is kind of nifty
Yeji so a while back my friend excuse me
Leena told me that she met this guy
called Daniel and she was falling for
him about a week later she texted me
that Daniel actually knew who I was and
that we used to go to the same
elementary school at first I didn't
remember a boy with that name so I
looked him up on Facebook and then
realized who he was Daniel and I did go
to school together but back then he he
used to identify as Diana oh yeah he
started his transitioning and changed
his name to Daniel about a year before
we finished school I tasted Lena that I
remembered him too and I remembered him
to be very nice I did consider whether I
should ask Lena if she knew dan used to
be I knew that it wouldn't be a problem
for her she's always been very
open-minded and she is pansexual mad I
did however decide it wasn't my place to
discuss that his gender if he wanted to
hurt Ana by he would tell her when he's
ready maybe she already knew
Lena kept talking about how happy she
was etcetera etcetera
then one night she called me asking if I
knew who done who used to be God and I
told her yes and then she said how could
I keep that from her oh when I knew the
whole time felt like I betrayed her
Daniel didn't know about Lena and did it
and neighbor expressing okay perfect so
long story short they fell out how close
were they were their best friends like
her and the girl not her and Daniel she
just says friend
thing they were good friends they
must've been good friends mm well I
don't necessarily I wouldn't say she's
the assault purely because if if my best
friend or my good friend is a
relationship with someone obviously the
more I feel like it's their position
let's save me you for example if if
you're in a really really strong
relationship and you've express how much
you like someone and I find out
something about that person I feel like
you must already know this like you
can't be so blind to the fact that this
is occurring if I can notice you sure
you must know this inclination yeah yeah
yeah there's something off so I wouldn't
want to be the one to be like Oh fYI x
y&z I would rather you asked me if I
knew then me knowing like that's the
question she I knew and when she asked
me I said yes I knew so that does that
make me the office I don't think it
makes me feel awful I feel like I would
be the are so far flama oh my god do you
know that about this your partner
blogger I think that's been and also
yeah is like I said if you're with
someone for X amount of time you must
know certain things about that person
mmm there must be something that could
have been a giveaway that he was
transept Trant
she was trans was he was he like him too
ago or guys what was it he was it was a
man it was a man transition to a girl so
she must the girlfriend must have
realized that or the boyfriend I'm so
confused I'm so confused right now so
wait wait the guy Daniel Daniel
so Daniel no it was it Diana from was it
that you Daniel used to be Diana so
where's the piece come from what you on
about Daniel used to be Diana yeah so
there's no peace Daniel used to be Diana
so how is she how was she ever
transsexual you've got no dick she's
just got no T's I don't know surgically
what's happened I just know what they're
identifying us and I'm assuming they
look like a guy now
yeah but if they're together they must
have had sex I'm assuming they haven't
had sex that's what I'm going off from
this that they haven't had sex obviously
she would know maybe when she said maybe
when she bailed her and I'm assuming
when she bailed her the next day and
said did you know that he used they used
to be Diana I'm assuming now they've got
to the sex part okay I'm assuming it had
to come out this okay okay okay ah I'm
assuming now okay she knows and she said
did you know the whole time cuz you said
you [ __ ] remembered her from school
that's a bit more sticky I feel like
then if I was in her shoes
the bredrin shoes if it was something
that early I would mention it you would
I would mention yeah because it's so
early into the game and yeah that
crucial effort whatever that's what
crucial information out I would say
something yeah because I feel like
there's no way there's no way in hell
you as my boy would not necessarily
forgive me but like you would if you
knew that I knew you would look at me
somehow like why don't you tell me kind
of thing because that's a life-changing
experience for him hmm as well as you do
you know I mean yeah yes I feel like if
I knew that information evidence Lu I'm
an [ __ ]
yeah because of how mu that relationship
was yeah yeah I fought in that scenario
they've been together nah she knew from
when they met okay so I would I would
have said Rex
straight away straight away but unless
like obviously me and someone who's
transgender isn't just your
run-of-the-mill everyday thing yeah so
like I can understand why she thought
like oh maybe I shouldn't say like if he
doesn't want to know what kind of thing
yeah but at the same time it's not
something that happens every day
so if I have afraid if one of you man
even if one of you man had like God was
on who's transgender and I know for I
know category that you've never been
with someone who's transgender before
I'm telling you yeah
if you've been with someone who's
transgender before that yeah
then I'm maybe I wouldn't yeah maybe I
think I'm assuming he must know yeah
yeah but if
something that I thought you definitely
didn't know yeah I'm I'm telling you I'm
telling you I never said Honda were the
big white sperm I'm telling you in a
second like big man did you know they
used to be dynamic you know what
yeah or vice versa an algorithm you know
used to be Daniel you're so what I would
be my heart would be racing I'll also be
excited at to laugh for me to tell him
I'll be scared for excited because I'll
be so oblivious to it I'm evil I have
your lipstick yet I would see you ready
start when I push you to our house house
you lips thank you because we begged a
year I abandoned near our kukuku Dan
Brown you would take pleasure in telling
me I would you will be funny you'll be
[ __ ] fine right rapidly rap